hello everyone and welcome to round six
of the 2019
I love Manchester namond it's a nikita
video versus mathias blue bomb and after
losing to you young G in the World Cup
after that crazy playoffs Nikita shaved
his head not completely I mean he really
shortened that I just don't have a fresh
photo of him so that's why I'm using
this one I know you guys really enjoy
fresh photos of players but until we get
one we were stuck with this one so
really an exciting game I'm very happy
that I did I saw it so I can share it
with you guys let's dive straight into
it so Vicky go with the white pieces
opens with C for the English opening is
on the board we have e six by blue bomb
Knight to c3 and the Knight to f6 with E
4 and now d5 the most common reply to
this idea and now II five another most
common reply here
I just pushing the knight back but black
of course doesn't back down he plays d4
with he captures on f6 this is the the
McKenna's variation with D captures on
c3 be captures on c3 preparing d4 and
black captures with the Queen Queen
captures on f6 and the d4 now okay White
has a bit of a messed up pawn structure
here but he has a lot of ways of
developing he can go very quickly
developed Knight of three Bishop g5 bish
from d3 the brooke has a semi-open
befall twos so definitely a lot of
compensation for white 4 and also it's
just strengthen the center so it's
really not an issue here with E 5 by
black and now Knight to f3 just
preparing to further develop with Bishop
to g5 e captures on d4 now before
recapturing with Bishop to g5 attacking
the Queen developing which tempo Quinta
a6 checked and now we have a Bishop to
e2 now here black continues development
we have Bishop to e7 I hope none of you
were considering to grab yet another
pawn because that's matin one so I know
none of you were actually thinking about
this but you know just to be sure
Bishop to e7 by black and now seek at
first indeed for it seems like the most
natural way to detect to recapture just
fixing your pawn structure also d5 is in
the works but here Knight characters on
d4 is the
move as it continues moving your pieces
forward the Queen is again under attack
and where do you go with the Queen now
there are a couple of moves that are
known here Queen d7 is a normal Queen D
sex is a normal Queenie five is a normal
but Queen to e4 is a new move in the
position but we will transpose into a
yet another known game because after
Bishop captures and Queen captures it's
pretty much the same where the Queen
recaptured from with castles and castles
and here there is one game that reached
this position between a 21 and the 2,300
player where they agreed to a draw so
any next move in this position is a
completely new move in the position so
here video player rook to e1 and it is
as a move 14 that we have a completely
new game so let's see where what the
game the where the game goes so you
don't want your Queen on the same file
as this rook so first black decided to
move the Queen Queen back to f6 so
that's already a lot of moves for the
Queen but okay Queen to Bishop to f3 by
white and now you're pressuring the
Queen side a lot it's not clear how
white will start how black will start
developing if you go nice characters
that white can just recapture also nice
the b5 is an idea but if you don't if
you just want to develop the bishop then
you lose the b7 point so here what you
want to do is sensible a white C points
are doubled there is no beep on or deep
on to challenge the c5 squared the way
you want to develop is nice the a6
followed by Knight to c5 and from the c5
squared the knight nicely covers b7
there's no way to kick the right away
from there then you develop your light
square bishop and then you get the rooks
into the game but here Bluebell tries
Queen to a6 yet another move with the
Queen and well you know there is a
general principle that you should not
bring your queen out there early into
the game but even if you do like you can
play the Scandinavian or there are
openings that allow this don't you know
just play around with with the Queen too
much here a v-cube of goes for Bishop
the d5 he defends his c4 pawn as the
Queen was attacking it and now he's
pretty much asking for c6 this is what
glue bond does he plays c6 and now okay
the engine just gives the bishop top
efore followed by Bishop the Queen
captures here as and black is
this is the engines idea but of course
Vito Gove has another idea after c6
video go goes for Bishop captures on f7
and it definitely makes sense blacks
queen is out of the game after black
plays c6 there's no way to bring the
Queen into the game I mean you could
play something like we need three file
and bring bring it back to these six but
it takes at least two moves and also
your Queen site is completely
undeveloped so here what do you what do
you do here the the thing is you have to
play King captures we're just gonna
quickly go over rook captures it loses
the rook to e8 check look blocks row
capture screen captures and now Queen to
f3 check King to g8 and now rook to e1
threatening rook to e8 mate so you have
to block it Bishop to d7 blocking the e8
square but now rook to e7 threatening
Queen f7 followed by Queen g7 checkmate
Queen captures on c4 just keeping an eye
on the f7 square and now Queen to g3
this is all for stand very beautiful
stuff the thread is just made on g6 on
g7 so after g6 now you go Queen to c7
threat and Queen the Queen to d8 and
after you prevent this you go Knights a
six now you just play Queen captures on
d7 and there is no defense against the
rook to g7 Czech followed by either
Queen to e7 mate or the rook will also
capture on h7 check the Queen will
follow on g7 mate so this is this is
game over
so after Bishop captures an f7 you
cannot capture with the rook can you
just go back with the king and say okay
you have this pawn and I'm just gonna
have a semi-open fall for my rook also
impossible because Queen to h5 now
threatens Bishop to g7 and you have to
somehow start defending Queen a3
trying to get your Queen into the game
but Bishop g6 and now after you play h6
Queen to h4 and now again how do you how
do you continue this game it's extremely
hard to do anything
the bishop doesn't have a good square to
be developed to if you develop with the
knight or something like that you just
get a knight of five next move Knight
characters and h6 and it's game over so
it's a it's a really hard hard position
for black unplayable white is winning
here so after Bishop captures an f7 blue
bomb has only one
option keen captures on f7 and now Queen
to h5 would check this is like this is
like a barbarians tutorial on how to
attack the Kings side and and I love it
it's just you know a sacrifice I have
seven play Queen h5 check that's that's
just very nice King to g8 bringing the
King back of course you have to guard
the h7 point and now rook to e8 just
offering the trade but of course the
real threat is just capture the look on
f8 and bring the other look into the
game so here the thing is for example
black is still better here but how do
you how do you proceed in this position
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find the best way to continue the
game for black while I give you a couple
of seconds for those of you who found
Queen to a3 it's the only good move for
black for example Queen to a3 now of
course rook will capture on f8 but not
just yet
first you will play c5 not allow the
Queen to get back into the game and now
black has to play something nice - a six
now you capture on f8 with check King
captures and now Queen captures on h7
and here after Queen captures on c3 you
will have some threats here the knight
is attack the rook is under attack and
after Queen h8 check King to f7 the game
continues and well blacks king is in a
very difficult position but if if white
will not be satisfied with a perpetual
it will be very hard for a white to
prove anything here but blue one played
Queen captures on c4 makes sense the
Queen has a very clear way of how to get
back into the game but now black is in
some serious trouble because that's just
not gonna work and if you look at it
black again played a move with the Queen
so we have rook captures nf8 King
captures and now not going for Queen
captures on h7 which a black was hoping
for maybe bring the Queen back into the
game
rook to e1 now threatening rook to e8
mate so Bishop to d7 blocking checkmate
and now Queen to g5 now threatening
Queen t7 check but also rook to e7 fall
by Quinta g7 is also a very nice
mate so Queen characters on c3 now of
course you cannot go for the rook lift
because Queen a1 will be will be
checkmate for black so Queen to d8 check
we have King to f7 and now Knight back
to f3 preparing Knight to e5 with check
and also Knight g5 is a possibility so
black first prevents this and the hopes
to get his King to safety with King g6
followed by King to h7 but now you get
Knight to e5 check even quicker was rook
to e7 check but it's a it's a really
brute forcing line with which requires a
lot of calculations but I will show it
for fun rook to e7 check King g6 and the
now Knight to e5 check yes the King does
hide on h7 but now you continue with the
rook captures on g7 with check King
captures and now okay the King didn't
have to go to h7 the King could have
gone further down the board but that's
just losing so we're just gonna show
this one a queen t7 check King h8 Queen
to f6 checking gauge 720 f7 check King
King h8 and now Knight to g6 is
checkmate nicely using the light squares
as the black queen is covering the dark
squares so rook to e7 winning here but
okay we have Knight the e5 check by
which you go and now you have to go
deeper into the into the position King
to e6 if if the black king could go
anywhere else I'm sure V to go would
have played the rookie 7 line and now
how do you continue this attack you
can't go for any nasty discoveries
because of Queen captures anyone so here
kink the f1 a beautiful attacking move
by with YouGov and now all sorts of
nasty discoveries are possible matte
blue bomb quickly on pins king 36 but
now just Knight captures on d7 you
cannot really recapture because rook to
d1 check will pick up again the knight
on d7 so Queen the d3 with check King to
G one and only now capture son d7 so
Knight character son d7 now there is no
rook to d1 but now of course Queen
character son is there was nothing
better with Queen to d2 attacking the
rook and look to f1 stepping back for
the moment and the Queen captures on a2
with Queen captures on b7 and now black
is up upon but
also the black king is wide open in the
center of the board and down the
exchange so rook and the Queen will be
will be deadly here with Queen to a4 and
now now guarding the d1 square but Queen
to be 2 now going after the g7 pawn
Knight to f6 blocking and now rook to e1
threatening Queen coming to e5
so Queen to a5 guarding the e5 score but
also attacking the rook on a one and now
Queen the d4 with Czech Knight to d5 and
now Queen to e5 check and it was in this
position unmoved 35 that Mathias blue
bomb resigned the game as if you go to
the seventh rank you start losing
material width check and if you go to c5
it's not much better
Roxy 1 check King b5 and not just Queen
captures and g7 you're the three points
each but the King is wide open and it
will be a slow but but sure death for
black in this position so of course a
blue bomb did not play this out but you
know who would so really really an
exciting game and really impressive
attack by Nikita fatigue of who after
after black played this Queen to a6 move
and after Bishop b5 even played c6 it
really just it begs you know just
capture on f7 and go for this attack
this is just very educational on how to
play when black plays a5 6 moves with
the Queen and completely disregards his
development it's I mean I'm even gonna
use this as a thumbnail but it's just a
very strange when something like this
happens to two of us such a strong
Grandmaster like Mathias blue bomb but
you know it just happens you play a
forced engine line and then all of a
sudden you find yourself with
undeveloped pieces and white just
sacrifices for the attack so very very
crazy stuff but yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank alexander belinda in the native
kögel which for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos you're thankful for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the isle of
man chess tournament checking up on your
suggestions and of course whatever
happens in the chess world so thank you
I will see you soon and have
excellent rest of your day